Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I have recently been witnessing a few heated
conversations regarding the submission of
deep learning papers to computer vision conferences.
The forums are up in arms about the fact that
despite some of these papers showcased remarkably
good results, they were rejected on the basis
of, from what I have heard, not adding too
much to the tree of knowledge. They argue
that we don't understand what is going on
in these neural networks and cannot really
learn anything new from them.
I'll try to understand and rephrase their
argument differently. We know exactly how
to train a neural network, it's just that
as an output of this process, we get a model
of something that resembles a brain as a collection
of neurons and circumstances under which these
neurons are activated. We store these in a
file that can take up to several gigabytes,
and the best solutions are often not intuitively
understandable for us.
For instance, in this video, we're training
a neural network to classify these points
correctly, but what exactly can we learn if
we look into these neurons? Now imagine that
in practice, we don't have a handful of these
boxes, but millions of them, and more complex
than the ones you see here.
Let's start with a simple example that hopefully
helps getting a better grip of this argument.
Now, I'll be damned if this video won't be
more than a couple minutes, so this is going
to be one of those slightly extended Two Minute
Paper episodes. I hope you don't mind!
The grammatical rules of my native language,
a lot of them, are contained in enormous tomes
that everyone has to go through during their
school years. Rules are important. They give
the scaffoldings for constructing sentences
that are grammatically correct.
Can we explain or even enumerate these rules?
Well, unless you are a linguist, the answer
is no.
Almost no one really remembers more than a
few rules, but every native speaker knows
how their language should be spoken. And it
is because we've heard a lot of sentences
that are correct and learned it by heart what
makes a proper sentence and what is gibberish.
This is exactly what neural networks do - they
are trained in a very similar way. In fact,
they are so effective at it that if we you
try to forcefully insert some of our knowledge
in there, the solutions are going to get worse.
It is therefore an appropriate time to ask
questions like what merits a paper and what
do we define as scientific progress. What
if we have extremely accurate algorithms where
we don't know what is going on under the hood,
or simpler, more intuitive algorithms that
may be subpar in accuracy. If we have a top
tier scientific conference where only a very
limited number of papers get accepted, which
ones shall we accept?
I hope that this question will spark a productive
discussion, and hopefully scientific research
venues will be more vigilant about this question
in the future.
Okay, so the question is crystal clear: knowledge
or efficiency? How about possible solutions?
Can we extract scientific insights out of
these neural networks?
Model compression is a way to essentially
compress the information in this brain-ish
thing, this collection of neurons we described
earlier.
To demonstrate why this is such a cool idea,
let's quickly jump to this program by DeepMind
that plays Atari games at an amazingly high
level. In breakout, the solution program that
you see here is essentially an enormous table
that describes what the program should do
when it sees different inputs. It is so enormous
that it has many millions of records in there.
A manual of many thousand pages, if you will.
It is easy to execute for a computer, but
completely impossible for us to understand
why and how it works.
However, if we intuitively think about the
game itself, we could actually write a super
simple program in one line of code that would
almost be as good as this. All we need to
do is try to follow the ball with the paddle.
One line of code, and pretty decent results.
Not optimal, but quite decent. From such a
program, we can actually learn something about
the game.
Essentially what we could do with these enormous
tables, is compressing them into much much
smaller ones. Ones that are so tiny, that
we can actually build an intuition from them.
This way, the output of a machine learning
technique wouldn't only be an extremely efficient
program, but finally, the output of the procedure
would be knowledge. Insight. If you think
about it, such an algorithm would essentially
do research by itself. At first, it would
randomly try experimenting, and after a large
amount of observations are collected, these
observations would be explained by a small
number of rules. That is exactly the definition
of research.
And perhaps, this is one of the more interesting
future frontiers of machine learning research.
And by the way, earlier we have talked about
a fantastic paper on Neural Programmer Interpreters
that also aimed to output complete algorithms
that can be directly used and understood.
The link is available in the description box.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!